[Música]
olá bem-vindos ao papo na arena é o
podcast semanal onde a gente indica
troca ideias sobre conteúdos que a gente
leu ouviu assistiu sempre trazendo a
visão de produto PR discussão eu sou o
Artur e eu tô bem empolgado com a
convidada de hoje viu e eu sou a x e eu
também porque convidado de hoje é uma
pessoa que a gente já citou dezenas de
vezes quase aqui no po Cash né Eh ela
trabalhou na Maquin passou pelo guia
bolso trabalhou ali muitos anos na pia
segurador e foi onde ela teve O Grande
Desafio da vida dela que ela me aguentar
todos os dias ali trabalhando comigo
então bem-vindo aí ao papo na arena
Alice gcias apresenta aí pra galera fala
pessoal tudo bem Vai ser um prazer estar
com vocês aqui hoje mais um dia aí
aturando AX na minha carreira eh eu sou
baiana eu fiz Unicamp fiz engenharia
elétrica lá e acabei indo pra França
ficar dois anos onde eu comecei a ter
meu primeiro contato com com tecnologia
eh eu fiz uma uma pós-graduação em
sistema de informações e também fiz um
estágio como q então Quality assurance e
quando eu voltei eu comecei minha
carreira na mckinsey fi dois anos
fazendo projetos de estratégia e de
operações inclusive de estratégia em
operações e de lá fazer um programa de
thout que é quando você fica um ano fora
daqu aqui se enquanto você estuda para
MBA essas coisas e e acabe indo pro guia
fazer ST out no guia bolso que é uma
Startup de eh gerenciamento financeiro
meus dois anos primeiros dois anos eu
fiquei em produto depois eu fiquei mais
dois anos em operações onde eu toquei a
operação de crédito Gu a bolsa e de lá
eu saí pra pia seguradora onde eu tocava
quatro áreas produto estratégia
precificação e aceitação de risco e a
parte de operações tanto dos produtos de
automóvel quanto de de celular e é tirei
um sabático aí nesse meio de tempo e
agora eu tô com venture Partner na na
canary passa demais Bora lá pras nossas
perguntinhas Artur Bora
lá e toma essa essa intro aí né só só
coisinha fácil aí mas vamos lá Alice
você falou bastante aí né Tipo você
passou um tempo na na Maquin e tals e
antes de você de fato ir para o mundo de
produto tecnologia startups no geral
assim como foi essa transição para você
e que habilidades que você acha que você
desenvolveu eh durante o período de
consultoria que te ajudaram e quais que
você acha que faltaram assim que você
teve que correr atrás para desenvolver
assim legal eh acho que o que mais me
ajudou foi a capacidade de estruturar
problemas e de realmente entender o
problema né o primeiro passo para você
conseguir estruturar um bom problema é
você entender qual é o problema então eu
diria que essa é a principal e a e tem
outras que ajudam Então quando você tá
em consultoria você trabalha muito a
questão de gestão de stakeholder que é
uma Skill necessária quando você tá
desenvolvendo produto você trabalha
muito questão de comunicação seja ela
bota up top Down quando você deve usar
cada um desses estilos de comunicação e
você quer usar mais para convencimento
você quer usar mais como
eh explicação mais ajudar a pessoa a
chegar no mesmo conclusão que você são
duas formas diferentes né de você
construir seu raciocino então eu diria
que o que eu herdei de consultoria foi
foram esses Skills e o que mais me
faltava era a capacidade de de testar
rápido de ter um mindset mais de colocar
coisa no ar ver o resultado Eu lembro
que no meu primeiro ano eu tava fazendo
análise e minha chefe tava olhando para
mim perguntando por que que você não
testou mesmo ainda para descobrir o
resultado em vez de estar analisando
eh Então essa visão de pô o que que eu
tenho que testar por que que eu tenho
que testar isso né E como que eu faço
para testar isso de uma forma eficiente
foi alo que eu tive que desenvolver ao
longo do tempo boa e mantendo Ness esse
mesmo assunto assim né de background
experiência consultoria eu sei também
que você é um perfil que você gosta de
trazer para times de produto né que que
você acha que você já falou um pouco do
que foram essas experiências que elas te
ajudaram né que que você acha que PMs
que não vem desse background de
consultoria deveriam focar em
desenvolver que esse perfil traz mais
sabe e que o mercado talvez não forme
mais não forme tanto quanto consultoria
forma
eu diria que os principais pontos são
entender o problema a fundo estruturar o
problema eu acho ele mais essa parte
mais importante do que a gestão de R E a
comunicação e o outro é Business Sens
então geralmente os pes que não vem de
consultoria eles têm esses dois Skills
que faltam né E aí isso impacta
diretamente a capacidade de priorização
que para mim é a capacidade mais
importante de um PM então eu diria que é
isso para você conseguir Izar bem como o
PM existem outras exas que você tem que
ter né eu digo o PM ele tem que ser um
generalista em tudo e por ser
generalista em tudo ele tem que
conseguir angariar o conhecimento de
todas as áreas para ele conseguir
priorizar muito bem isso envolve ter
Business Essência envolve ter
atendimento do cliente envolve
atendimento de tecnologia e até ali um
pouco de entendimento de marketing pô é
impossível alguém ser profundo em todas
essas áreas Então para mim o ele tem que
conseguir ser superficial em todas elas
para conseguir priorizar muito bem e
para priorizar muito bem você também tem
que conseguir estruturar muito bem o
problema e aí eu acho que é isso quando
você não tem Business Sens às vezes
prioriza muito orientado a cliente mas
tá como se impacta o negócio quando você
não estrutura bem o problema e nem
muitas vezes o problema está resolvendo
né não total e e acho que vale até
entrar um pouco nessa parte de Business
sense né fala pra galera que que você
entende de como Business
sense Que diferença que isso faz pro
trabalho de um PM né Acho que você deu
até um exemplo pô Às vezes o cara
prioriza muito pro produto muito pro
cliente não prioriza pro negócio né n em
situações onde uma uma situação funciona
melhor ou você deveria pesar mais para
um lado né para mim Business Essência
você tem que entender para onde o
negócio está indo por que que ele está
indo Quais são os diferenciais
competitivos tá querendo criar qual que
o seu posicionamento de mercado você
entender essa esse todo né entender cara
como que o meu negócio para de pé Quais
são as alavancas que fazem com que ele
pare de pé e aí a sua priorização ela
varia muito sim Você sempre tem que
entender o cliente você sempre deveria
estar fazendo coisas que dir finalment
melhor a vida do seu cliente senão você
não vende seu produto no limite mas se
você faz algo que é tão bom pro cliente
mas que você não faz com que o negócio
pare de pé também não funciona né então
muitas vezes é um equilíbrio em relação
a essas coisas e aí eu acho que para
entender onde você prioriza é você
entender o que que é a visão do seu
negócio e a visão do seu produto então
na Pier por exemplo né quando a gente
falou de fazer CL instantâneo era uma
coisa que é excepcional pro cliente
Então imagina celular foi roubado você
recebe na mesma hora do lado de de
negócio também é super interessante a
gente tava fazendo análise de Clan de
forma 100% automatizada então a gente
conseguiu automatizar 20% dos clanes e a
gente tinha uma das coisas que fazia o
nosso negócio parar de p era ser mais
eficiente do que o mercado pra gente
poder ter um pel melhor então foi uma
priorização que a gente fez que
impactava os dois quando a gente olhava
em alto o nosso funil de contratação a
gente terava muito ele para que ele
fosse cada vez mais fácil pro cliente
mas que também aumentasse a conversão
então também era bom pros dois aí tem
casos que não você não consegue chegar
nesse caminho por exemplo no sinistro de
automóvel você precisa de mais tempo
para analisar o sinistro então a gente
sempre debatia muito como que a gente
faz para ter um clã instantâneo
automóvel e a gente nunca Conseguiu
chegar nesse desenho Porque pô se o
carro foi roubado a gente tem que saber
se V recuperar o carro ou não né mas aí
a gente pensava tá o que que pode ser
relevante o suficiente pro cliente pra
gente automatizar e tentar fazer
instantâneo então por exemplo Ó seu
sinistro ele já tá aprovado caso seu
carro não seja encontrado você vai ser
pago então não é 100% mas você começa a
fazer algo que é mais orientado ali e
você tenta encontrar um bom Mix PR os
dois né bom E aproveitando esse tópico
aí lembrar vocês que o jabazinho aqui no
meio aqui para lembrar que tem curso de
pensamento crítica e analítico e que a
gente fala bastante sobre isso sobre o
business sobre entender mais negócios
métricas financeiras econômicas e como
fazer todas essas conexões Ah e
causalidades assim H dia 29 do vocês
online ao vivo e dia 6/07 presencial
aqui em São Paulo e o descontinho como
sempre tá no link da descrição aqui e
uma outra coisa que tem a ver também com
o pensamento crítico e analítico que a
gente falou no podcast que a gente foi a
fundo nesse assunto né então se você
quer aprofundar umas duas três edições
atrás a gente faz um programa mais
focado nisso mas tem muito a ver é
Skills de problem solving né que você
comentou também né Alice Alice eu já
citei isso aqui no no podcast foi a
pessoa que me ajudou a me desenvolver em
problem solving que falou véi você tem
que botar isso no seu PDI ó é isso isso
isso e tal e depois ela ficava mandando
todo mundo conversar comigo para eu
ajudar as pessoas porque eu tinha tido
que estudar isso né e é muito mais fácil
você e falar pras pessoas como você
aprendeu algo do que algo que é inato
para você né e é um assunto recorrente
aqui no podcast eu queria que você
falasse um pouquinho Alice dos gaps que
você normalmente vê em PM sobre isso o
que que você acha que eles podem fazer
para melhorar nesse aspecto né boa que
eu mais vejo GAP é a galera pulando
direto pra solução então em vez de
pensar em estruturar o problema entender
o problema mais a fundo é falar a gente
precisa melhorar x E aí a pessoa já
começa a falar pô a gente pode fazer
tudo isso aqui para melhorar x Tá mas e
o que que esse que que fazer isso tá
ajudando o cliente que problema de
negócio que ele tá resolvendo de forma
geral que o problema tá sendo resolvido
ao fazer isso né E aí eu acho que
existem várias forma de você desenvolver
problem solving e
inclusive estudou bastante esse assunto
gente vocês podem pedir várias dicas
para ele tá eu acho que um dos programas
anteriores eu deixei o DOC que eu peguei
inclusive na época que eu fiz então eu
boto aí no link da na descrição também
dessa edição Eu gosto muito de um
conceito que é 70% do seu aprendizado
vem fazendo algo
então a forma como você mais aprende
algo é fazendo né então fala que 70% vem
dali 20%
vem de você ver como os outros fazem e
10% vem de estudo e eu li isso em algum
lugar eu não vou lembrar Qual é a
referência Mas o que eu lembro é mais ou
menos dessa divisão e se você pensar o
que dá mais trabalho é estudo por um
lado estudo ele te dá fundamento O que é
muito bom mas eu acho que é muito
importante você
balancear o como que você tá aprendendo
as coisas então para mim a melhor forma
de você aprender problem solv e é como
eu geralmente tento aprender algo é eu
começo conversando com alguém que é bom
eu tento aplicar e depois eu estudo
porque quando você começa estudando
minha visão minha percepção é que você
não sente as dores você ainda não sabe o
que que você não vai saber E então você
você v tanta coisa que você tem que
estudar que às vezes até paralisa né
você fala meu Deus é muita coisa nesse
tópico e quando você começa executando
você começa a falar hum mas eu travei
aqui eu vou estudar Isso aqui e aí você
é muito mais eficiente no seu estudo
sendo que estudar é a coisa que mais
demanda tempo apesar de ser de onde vem
10% do seu conhecimento ele é o que mais
requer tempo então é é um processo que
eu gosto de fazer em geral para aprender
qualquer coisa conversar com gente muito
boa tentar aplicar e depois começar a
estudar nos lugares que eu vou travando
para ir tendo um pouco mais de
fundamento então eu sugiro fazer isso
quando eu tava aprendendo problem
solving eu entrava num restaurante eu
começava a tentar estimar Qual era
receita quando as pessoas passavam por
dia qualquer coisa você pode est andando
na rua você pode pensar quantos prédios
Será que tem nessa rua você pode chamar
qualquer coisa quantas pessoas por dia
passam aqui quantas A galera gosta
daquele do bolinha de golf né quantas
bolinhas de golf cabem nessa sala é
quant quant pinguins tem na Antártica
qualquer coisa literalmente como é que
você estima qualquer coisa sem ter
referências isso é um jeito de você
treinar problem solving e a ISO que você
vai aprendendo vai testando vai
treinando vai aprendendo Você não vai
falar sobre miss Ah podemos isso é um
conceito né E aí existem vários
conceitos no PR sou a gente pode falar
de árvores por exemplo que você adora e
né a Teresa Torres que você
amava no fim a estrutura de uma árvore é
para você deixar algo m né é tudo conect
S também
eh uma uma árvore quando você tá fazendo
brainstorming ela não precisa ser miss
né mas uma árvore de resolução de
problema geralmente sim eh mas é em
geral é miss é MSE mutualmente exclusivo
coletivamente exaustivo e é o conceito
de que quando você tenta resolver um
problema é importante que ele enderece o
todo é o coletivamente exaustivo e que
ele não tenha nenhuma interseção entre
ele que é o é o mutualmente exclusivo né
é difícil entender quando fala assim a
minha dica é digite Miss no Google
coloquem imagens e eles vão ter ali duas
imagenzinha ciclos e E aí geralmente
fica muito mais claro do que do que
falando assim mas é é algo de fato
importante PR na parte de
PR e a conta de padeiro também né Acho
que todos esses exemplos que você deu
inclusive de quanto quanto de receita
tem nesse restaurante quantas bolinhas
de Gol ficarem numa sala você nunca vai
saber exatamente né mas as estimativas e
as contas de padeiro ajudam nisso é um
pedaço relevante do do seu problem
solving o next step é você conseguir
priorizar E aí para você priorizar se
você tentar estimar tudo que tá ali de
forma muito detalhada você vai passar
sua vida estimando então acho que um
Skill Super Interessante de desenvolver
que também desenvolve fazer esse tipo de
exercício é as contas de padeiro o a é
um pouco traumatizado com esse tema que
às vezes ele passava um dia inteiro para
fazer a conta eu fazia em 5 minutos e
dava assim um número próximo não que era
igual mas era próximo
eh mas que isso veio de muito treino
assim né não não veio do do nada mas é
importante é pô pensar em como que eu
simplifico isso né para eu conseguir
chegar numa boa estimativa e a conta de
poder ela também serve muito para você
fazer Double check então será que esse
número tá fazendo sentido que que eu
posso usar como referência para
conseguir fazer um cheque se esse número
tá direcional correto e 90% das vezes o
número ele não precisa est exato se ele
tiver na direção certa tá valendo assim
e que muda se a conversão vai ser 2% ou
2.1 2.2 então se tiver dentro de uma
margem de erro que tá razoável tá tudo
bem assim né O que você quer saber é se
a ordem de grandeza tá fazendo sentido e
conta de padeira é muito bom para isso
também o ponto que você falou aí sobre a
conta de padeiro ajudar nessa
simplificação e no final ela acaba
ajudando na simplificação não só das
contas no final das contas Porque quanto
mais você fica bom na conta de pader o
raio simplificador você consegue até
mesmo para tipo pros problemas né as
soluções que você vai trazer depois de
você identificar os problemas vai ficar
muito mais prático também né você
consegue ter começar a simplificar as
coisas lógico dentro de um Range bom né
suficiente assim para conseguir fazer
essas simplificações e etc né ela acaba
expandindo muito mais do que só a conta
de padeiro né é e até assim eu lembro
muito em apresentações então a gente
tinha uma semanal em que os líderes
levantavam como é que estava os
resultados que a gente tava vendo eu
pegava muito erro em conta de fazendo
conta de padeira de Double check assim
então olhava pro falava gesse número não
tá certo não hein vamos vamos verificar
isso aí não sei não e era tudo conta de
padeiro porque eu não tinha menor assim
eles às vezes faziam umas análises
mirabolantes eh e aí tinham errado
alguma coisinha pequena e às vezes essas
contas de padeira ajudavam nesse tipo de
Double check no dia a dia sabe eu eu
acho que dá uma habilidade muito grande
de trazer sensatez pros números sabe ver
se tá direcional gentee falando bom ali
muito bom enfim e ao longo da sua
carreira uma coisa que você teve que
fazer bastante aí foi montagem e
organização de times né Não só de
produto e quais são suas dicas aí para
líderes de como criar a estrutura de um
time Como identificar a hora de crescer
como decidir Que perfil contratar conta
um pouquinho aí a Alice montando team
boa eu acho que a primeira coisa você
tem que decidir qual que vai ser a
estrutura organizacional do seu time né
E aí não existe estrutura organizacional
perfeita então geralmente né toda a
estrutura ela vai te trazer benefícios e
malefícios E aí você tem que entender o
que que você tá querendo otimizar com
aquela estrutura então por exemplo na
pira a gente poderia organizar por bu
por exemplo automóvel smartphone a gente
poderia organizar a estrutura por
jornada que que é o benefício malefício
de cada uma se você organizar por
Business unit o grande benefício é que
você tenha uma visão completa do seu
produto Então você tem alguém que
entende aquele produto de ponta a ponta
e e consegue otimizar tudo que você
precisa daquele produto o que que é o
malefício Você não tem uma pessoa que tá
olhando aquisição de uma forma Global
Você não tem uma pessoa que tá olhando
pra jornada do cliente de uma forma
global e se o cliente tiver os dois
produtos o que acontece outro problema
que gerava quando a gente era organizado
por Business units era que a priorização
ela se dava dentro das Business units
então era mais difícil você distinguir
Ah eu quero priorizar mais alto do que
smartphone como você muda isso rápido é
não trivial né porque o time ele já tá
alocado então Toda vez que você quer
fazer uma mudança de priorização em
relação a recursos ela é mais dolorida
eh ela era muito mais fácil Se você
queria priorizar entre aquisição vers
satisfação Porque aí fal não galera todo
mundo aí do time de auto do smartphone
foca mais em aquisição ou mais
insatisfação do cliente e E você tem o
problema ao contrário quando você tá com
a jornada de aquisição e jornada do
cliente e clan que era o nosso caso e
quando você tá organizado por jornada
você não tem ninguém vendo produto de
ponta a ponta então não tem ninguém
também que entende o produto de ponta a
ponta então sempre vai ter os tradeoffs
E aí você tem que pensar o que que você
quer otimizar o que que você quer
maximizar e o segundo ponto é como que
você reduz os problemas Como que você
trabalha os problemas que essa estrutura
te traz E aí Geralmente vem a governança
então quando eu penso em governança eu
penso em rotinas rituais e e até
estrutura de responsabilidades que vão
Minimizar os problemas da sua estrutura
organizacional para mim Esse é um dos
grandes objetivos do que do que você faz
em relação a essa governança mais do seu
time né que é diferente de uma
governança de empresa que você tem
outras coisas você tá olhando também
então é é ess é a primeira coisa que eu
penso tá E aí eu sinto que tem momentos
eu já vi alguns times serem criados sem
sem isso ser tão consciente aí sobre
identificar a hora de
crescer existe um conceito assim eu acho
que tem duas coisas que são muito tricks
assim né Quanto mais sor é uma pessoa
que você traz pro seu time mais demanda
ela vai ela vai gerar por porque essa
pessoa by design tem mais visão Então
ela enxerga mais coisa para fazer É
muito difícil você trazer um gerente
para um time e ele não falar que ele
precisa de três coordenadores é muito
difícil porque ele vai enxergar coisa
suficiente para três coordenadores fazer
ele vai enxergar coisa suficiente para
10 coordenadores fazer que se ele não
tiver enxergando isso tudo você
contratou o gerente errado provavelmente
E então eu acho que tem uma uma coisa
aqui para você escolher quando você tá
querendo crescer é qual o nível de
senioridade eu vou trazer para essa vaga
E como que eu vou aliar as expectativas
com essa pessoa do nível de recurso que
ela vai ter ao longo do tempo se você
trouxer um gerente para trabalhar com um
analista você tem criar muito bem a
expectativa desse gerente de que cara
você só vai ter um time com quatro cinco
coordenadores daqui h x anos tá beleza
Eh você entende que você vai enxergar
mais coisas para fazer do que isso E aí
é eu acho que entender essa essa
expectativa de crescimento da empresa te
ajuda a entender Qual que é o tamanho da
cadeira que você tem que trazer a cada
momento e aí o momento específico de
crescer eu acho que ele é muito mais uma
questão da empresa né Qual que é a
estratégia da empresa para aquele
momento e aí isso varia bastante então
pô se a empresa que ela tá com
expectativa muito grande que ela vai ter
um bom caixa faz muito sentido você
focar mais em times de produto e
Tecnologia se a empresa que vai estar
com menos caixa você vai focar mais em
cresc time de operações Então acho que
varia bastante a estratégia de
crescimento do time de acordo com que é
o momento da empresa assim eu diria mais
isso E aí faltou o perfil para contratar
né isso nó Issa aí varia loucamente hein
então o perfil tem essa parte da
senioridade que eu falei um pouco eu
tendo a começar com perfis mais seniors
então quanto menor o time mais Senior eu
tendo a começar o perfil assim
eh porque você quer entregar autonomia
né E aí se você começa trazendo pessoas
muito Júniors pro time você vai ter que
tomar muita parte da decisão então eu
tendo Trazer Alguém já um pouco mais
Senior que vai vai criar mais perna até
porque você não tem não tem estrutura
você não tem processo você não tem nada
quando você tá construindo Startup muito
no começo então você não consegue dar o
direcionamento suficiente para alguém
muito Júnior aí eu acho que essa essa
questão do perfil Ela depende de tantas
coisas né então é qual o estágio que a
empresa Tá qual estágio que a área tá o
que que essa posição requer que é meio
difícil falar de forma tão abrangente
não sei se vocês querem é eu acho que
tem uma parada interessante também que é
de Skills complementares né de de tanto
olhar paraa Skill que a cadeira precisa
quanto para Skills que seu time não tem
E como que você complementa ele né e
acho que tem tem vários até várias
formas de você olhar o que são Skills né
Eh eu gosto muito de olhar em bti por
exemplo M bti que tem aquele I né que é
o introvertido extrovertido O noos que é
uma pessoa mais detalhista uma pessoa
com visão mais Global eh o f o t que é o
feeling o Thinking e o p e o J que é uma
pessoa que enxerga mais todo essa
processual eh Então isso é uma forma de
você enxergar complementaridade porque
geralmente essas pessoas elas enxergam
coisas diferentes você tem a
complementaridade de Skills mais a
comunicação versus uma capacidade de
estruturação de problema versus uma
pessoa mais criativa eh e que consegue
também eh disrupt mais o que você tá
fazendo versus um Skill mais de
liderança e você pode olhar uma questão
de diversidade também eh para você
conseguir até trazer diversidade de
pensamentos você pode olhar eh pessoas
que já trabalharam mais com b2c b2b você
pode olhar também pessoas que já
trabalharam mais com growth mais com
retenção que aí são Jobs mais
específicos você pode olhar uma pessoa
que já trabalhou mais com tema que você
quer então tem muitas formas de você
olhar complementaridade de Skill né E aí
eu acho que depende muito da sua
estratégia de de construção de time de
você entender o que que meu time precisa
aonde meu time precisa disso E como que
eu posso complementar é todas essas é
isso trazer uma pessoa Às vezes parece
mais simples do que é
né Mas é interessante ir montando esse
quebra-cabeça uma coisa que você falou
que eu fiquei lembrando aqui também tava
lá na na iuse também que era seguradora
um pouco antes da Pier inclusive e a
gente teve Exatamente Essa só quando a
gente foi estruturar os times assim e a
primeira versão a gente optou por ter
cada time pelas Business units então a
gente tinha o time que cuidava do seguro
alto o time que cuidava do seguro caro
cas e tudo mais e depois a gente fez a
quebra depois a gente reestruturou para
ir por jornada porque depois de um tempo
a gente já tinha aprendido bastante
coisa sobre os produtos qual era o carro
chefe qual que não era e tudo mais a
gente falou beleza agora dá para
otimizar as coisas tanto é que no
primeiro momento às vezes até
assistências que tinham produtos difer
diferentes era a mesma assistência mas a
maneira de solicitar e contratar era
diferente e depois a gente simplificou
isso estruturando mais no aspecto da
jornada né Mas você falou me lembrei
muito disso de como também tem isso né
de Às vezes o que faz sentido para um
momento depois você vai ter que ir pro
pro outro estágio né pro outro pro outro
perfil né pro outro tem também o Como
que você pensa para desde o começo você
já mitigar esses problemas então por
exemplo você pode ter um fórum para você
discutir jornada de sinistro Você pode
ter um líder de Jornada de um designer
que é líder de jornada que é responsável
por garantir que é jornada de sinistro
ela tá minimamente coerente você pode
fazer alguns hazin na estrutura e tá
tudo bem A única coisa que eu aconselho
é não super complique a estrutura no
começo não faça estrutura matricial por
causa disso assim você vai gerar tanta
complexidade no seu Business isso aqui
obviamente vai depender do estágio que
você tá Se você chegar num estágio que
sua empresa tem 3000 pessoas faça uma
estrutura matricial e mas no estágio que
a sua empresa tem 100 pessoas não façam
estrutura matricial porque você vai
deixar o seu negócio tão mais complexo
que não vai vale a pena então é para mim
como é que você cria rockzinho sabe você
pode ser ter um líder pode ser ter um
ritual ter uma rotina e é por isso que
esse modelo de governança né que a
governança ela envolve tanto os ritos
quanto essa estrutura que a gente
geralmente usa o o rass né a estrutura
de responsabilidades te ajuda a resolver
sabe eu concordo muito com isso mas
pensar nesses hacks também é super
interessante massa e agora falando do
momento novo da sua carreira né você fez
consultoria depois operação e produto e
agora você é venture Partner na canary
né Fala um pouquinho desse papel que que
faz um venture Partner o que que é o seu
trabalho como que tá sendo mais essa
transição de carreira você transição de
certa forma né Tem tem muitas
semelhanças ali mas conta pra gente boa
eh primeiro lugar assim foi muita sorte
essa essa posição eh eu comecei em Junho
do ano passado a estudar tese para
empreender minha ideia é começar a
montar minha própria empresa e aí nesse
processo eu fiquei muito próxima do do
Florian que é um dos sócios da canary e
apresentando os estudos que eu tava
fazendo e p como que eu olhava as teses
ele falou ali se eu tô querendo montar
uma área de research aqui dentro que que
é o conceito dessa área né então um dos
grandes Desafios de um founder é
encontrar uma tese e é Um Desafio que pô
é difícil assim e no fundo ele tem uma
posição melhor do que um uma pessoa para
conseguir encontrar boas teses então pô
a caner ela tá o tempo inteiro em
contato com Fundos que estão lá fora
eles recebem muitas teses por dia então
eles têm uma visão do que tá acontecendo
no mercado muito mais apurado do que o
indivíduo e isso gera uma capacidade de
gerar boas ideias e aí o que eu faço
hoje é explorar essas boas ideias para
entender se elas realmente são boas ou
não Então apesar deles terem a
capacidade de expar essas boas ideias
eles não tinham a capacidade de
aprofundar nelas e entender elas fazem
sentido ou não e agora o que eu tô
fazendo é isso né eles têm a capacidade
de pegar uma ideia pronta e avaliar se
ela faz sentido ou não né mas não de
pegar uma ideia Ah será que eu fazer eh
ai para vendas faz sentido sei lá no
primeiro nível parece que sim né como
que eu valido para afirmar que é um step
anterior né da da ideia validada é
exatamente E aí então o meu papel é hoje
é ajudar a montar essa área de research
com o principal objetivo de ajudar
founders a darem o próximo passo eh
ajudar founders to be né que a gente
chama São pessoas que querem ser
founders mas ainda não são mas mas a
minha ideia é empreender então espero eu
que uma dessas ideias eu vou gostar
tanto que eu vou falar essa aqui é minha
é então foi um caminho interessante que
a gente encontrou de eu ajudar uma
necessidade que a caner tinha no momento
e ajudar o meu momento de carreira que a
querer emprender juntou o bom dos dois
mundos aí mas tem sido divertido e teve
algumas perguntas aqui que eu não
respondi então
é o que é um venture part venture é o
papel mais aleatório que existe no fundo
que ele pode ser qualquer coisa
então é o funcionário do fundo né pode
fazer qualquer coisa é isso ele é cada
ventor Partner que você conversar vai
fazer uma coisa diferente então ele é
assim ó essa pessoa está me ajudando em
algo é isso que ela quer dizer é um
pouco diferente do entrepreneur
Residence né que o entrepreneur resid
geralmente ele tá ajudando uma tese
dentro do fundo é o venture Partner ele
tá ajudando a construir algo dentro do
fundo né mas então acho que no meu caso
específico essa área de research e tem
sido interessante assim eu tenho
aprendido muito como um fundo avalia
empresas para fazer investimento nelas
como um fundo pensa e eu acho que isso
também é um Skill interessante para
quando eu fui empreender e tem sido
muito interessante também para eu
conhecer para ampliar minha rede de
contatos né então eu tenho conversado
com muito empreendedor com muito Fundo
de Investimento e também é algo que eu
valorizo bastante para essa jornada
assim massa inclusive um salve aqui pro
floran daqui a pouco a gente podia
chamar o flor também para vir aqui
mandar um salve bom e antes da gente
entrar no papum al das perguntas do
rapidinhas Vira e Mexe eu trago uma
frase aqui no no programa que é trabalhe
trabalhe trabalhe não se esqueça que as
vírgulas significam paudo e além de
consultoria você passou em várias
empresas em estado de crescimento
acelerado como guia bolso e Pier també e
você passou um bom tempo também Depois
disso tirando um um tempo para você né
tirando um sabático queria entender um
pouquinho Como foi esse seu processo
Qual foi o principal sinal que você
percebeu que tava na hora mesmo de de
dar um descanso conta um pouquinho aí
como foi boa a empresa que eu mais
Trabalhei na vida foi a Maquin tá E lá
acho que é você é jovem né você aguenta
então e eu trabalhava muito na Maquin
teve projeto que eu cheguei a trabalhar
16 horas por dia era era insanidade E aí
como no guia bolso quando eu fui a ideia
era só passar um ano e acabei ficando
quatro eu fui sem fazer nenhuma pausa né
E aí quando eu saí do guia bolso eu
tinha se anos seguidos trabalhando com
poucas pausas E aí eu falei cara eu
preciso de um tempo e aí eu fiz uma
acordo comigo mesma que era eu nunca
mais ia sair do emprego sem pegar tempo
para mim assim quando você sai de férias
trabalhando você desliga mas demora
assim o meu tempo de desligar é duas
semanas pelo menos Ô e não é tão comum a
gente tirar duas semanas de férias tem
gente que tira duas semanas de férias é
isso normalmente é duas semanas né É
você não é difícil né a gente tirar um
mês seguido não é muito nosso perfil Eu
sinto que a gente não tem um tempo real
para desligar e assim as coisas estão
acontecendo então Sempre tem aquela
preocupação Zinha sabe no fundo você às
vezes recebe um Slack de alguma coisa
mais urgente um WhatsApp então eu sinto
que quando você sai do trabalho Acabou
Não tem essa preocupação e eu não
consigo e para mim é o melhor momento
que existe para você aproveitar esse
tempo assim então eu tenho muito forte
comigo hoje então é menos uma questão de
Em que momento eu entendi para mim foi
mais uma questão de um acordo comigo
mesmo e eu me planejo financeiramente
para isso toda vez
[Música]
bom Bora pro nosso papum Então vamos lá
gerenciamento de produto em um tweet
nó esse não foi tão papum
né mas é Logo você que é boa de síntese
Olha só eu diria que é priorize Entenda
os riscos Entenda como mitigar esses
riscos com os testes simples e qual que
é a principal habilidade de uma pessoa
de produto priorização boa tem algum
livro que você recomenda pra galera e
não precisa ser um livro técnico de
produto nem nada pode ser um livro
qualquer tá eu tô lendo agora um que
chama é dopamin notion é notion dopamina
não sei a ordem exatamente mas é noção
dopamina nação dopamina e E ele fala do
como a nossa sociedade atual ela leva a
gente a ter essas esses estímulos de
dopamina rápidos né e o que que a gente
deveria estar fazendo para se
desvincular desses estímulos Acho super
interessante e e muito associada a a
todos os estímulos que a gente tem hoje
né então eu gosto dele tô gostando tô
lendo ainda então tô gostando esse livro
tá na minha lista inclusive porque ele
tá como se você assina o aud bow ele tá
como o livro lá que você pode ler el de
no no esquema de graça lá eu coloquei na
minha lista aqui para para começar ele
eu nunca eu sempre acabo pegando outro
livro não começo ele mas agora vou
priorizá-lo recomendo recomendo
interessante ele e qual série que você
tá vendo no momento aí Yellow Stone ou é
que vocês V lá não agora é porque essa
tá na minha lista o livro tava na lista
do Artur e a l Stone tá na minha lista
de séries eu acabei de assistir Band of
Brothers que é bem interessante que é
sobre a Segunda Guerra Mundial e aí
agora eu tô assistindo el loston boa e
qual sua música cantor disco Favorito
prilet pode ser do momento pode ser da
vida eu tenho uma música que eu uso pré
reuniões importantes Essa é inusitada
hein Kelly clon stronger é a minha
música do Power position pré reuniões
ISO aí ó is é uma curiosidade boa
hein eu acho que eu já soube disso Em
algum momento eu esquecido completamente
dessa informação muito bom ela me anima
muito eu faço muito Power position com
ela pulo grito Aí eu entro na reunião an
daça vai ter reunião com investidor
mesmo super uso e coisa que você não não
abre mão na sua rotina dormi bem dormi 8
horas eu não dormi Minas 8 horas Jesus e
você você do tipo acompanha nos Gadgets
da vida como foi seu sono etc tal para
garantir que isso foi tá indo bem ou não
eu tento ter uma rotina de sono Uma
rotina pré sonono né boa assim então
geralmente e às 9 horas eu tento tirar
todos os eletrônicos é muitas vezes
momento que eu vou ler fazer alguma
coisa diferente qualquer coisa às vezes
eu começo a num casa seesse horário
qualquer coisa eh ex vizinho deve adorar
né A vizinha que começa a arrumar a casa
9 da noite Lig o aspirador na casa né
e mas eu tento às 9 tirar começar a
tirar tudo que é eletrônico para 10
horas tá dormindo e aí eu acordo às 6 Eu
muitas vezes deixo o pedaço da fresta da
janela aberta e acordo com luz do sol
quando eu acordo tento olhar pra luz
tento olhar para fora para já ir
Ganhando esse estímulo do dia isso
também impacta o sono né então é super
interessante que os estudos mostram que
isso impacta o sono depois e eu tento
fazer o meu começo de dia também sem
celular então acordo muitas vezes eu
alongo tomo banho aí como ovo como
minhas frutas aí eu vou pegar no celular
então tem quase ali uma hora que eu fico
sem massa e para finalizar o nosso papum
qual que é seu produto Favorito Eu gosto
do aud viu É ele aumentou muito a minha
capacidade de ler assim então ler entre
aspas né É exatamente consumir conteúdos
de leitura O Artur é big fã também Nossa
cara eu escuto muito mas uma coisa que
eu que eu fico que eu Putz preciso eu
não arrumei ainda um hack para isso mas
que é na hora que você tá escutando algo
você de alguma maneira conseguir fazer
salvar aquele parada ali sem ter que
pegar o celular e etc poder Pô gostei
dessa parte aqui D um highlight isso aí
para mim daqui a pouco eu olho direito
mas ainda não não consegui isso assim
mas nossa eu li o li né vou não consigo
não usar o ler aqui gente vou usar o ler
eh eu li o livro do Barack Obama você
sente que ele tá sentado do seu lado de
contando a vida dele eu acho assim
impressionante eh esse esquema que eles
fizeram do próprio autor muitas vezes
contar o livro eu acho que traz uma uma
proximidade assim muito diferente porque
é é ele contando da forma que ele quer
que seja contado sabe não é você lendo
do jeito que você acha que ele tá
fazendo eh e eu acho eu eu acho isso
muito interessante assim então não sei
eu gosto gosto bastante acho traz um
pouco da da força do podcast até né que
podcast muitas pessoas gostam porque tem
essa proximidade do as pessoas sentem
que elas estão próximas do dos
apresentadores do podcast e tal e acho
que na leitura é isso com o Plus que é
uma narrativa de Fato né então é o que
você falou d d dá todo o tom da
narrativa do jeito que a pessoa quer eu
gosto muito é para mim foi é um produto
muito bom assim inclusive eh você falou
disso tem um outro livro também que é
muito disso que é o 100 dias entre o céu
e o mar lá do Amir clink que é também
ele narrando e tudo mais e que dizem que
é muito legal o Lucas que tá sempre
escutando aqui com a gente já falou que
fez essa experiência inclusive quando
ele tava fazendo a travessia pra África
e que do tipo foi foi muito massa assim
também então realmente é diferente né á
[Música]
E com isso a gente encerra o programa de
hoje né mais um product Hero aí entregue
Então queria aproveitar Alice Muito
Obrigado aí pelo seu tempo por bater
esse papo com a gente foi um super
programa aí acho que os nossos ouvintes
vão curtir para caramba e aí se quiser
deixar um recado final aí pra galera
algo que você queira trazer o espaço é
seu manda verô galera foi um prazer est
aqui com vocês Espero que vocês tenham
gostado Espero que de alguma forma eu
consiga contribuir com a jornada de
produto de vocês eh e foi um prazer tá
aqui bom Alice Muito obrigado pela
participação aí por todos os a aula que
você deu aí hoje
e então é isso galera se você curtiu né
Compartilha esse episódio merece ser
compartilhado não que os outros não
precisam mas esse Também merece ser
compartilhado aí com outras pessoas
então adiciona sua playlist compartilha
com a galera segue a gente lá nas redes
tanto no Instagram quanto no Twitter
quanto no Linkedin @arena @ur close comk
@x e é isso aí a gente se vê semana que
vem valeu valeu